اشعلت الاتهامات التي وجهت لترامب بشان
دفع اموال لممثله اباحيه لاسكاتيا قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2016
اشعلت التصريحات بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين
واول من انتقد هذا القرار هو الرئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي الجمهوري
الذي اكد ان المدعي العام في منهات
الديمقراطي الفن براج اضر ببلاده بشكل لا
يمكن اصلاحه لمحاوله للتدخل في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه حسب قوله اما في المقابل اشاد
ديمقراطيون بنظام العداله الامريكي التي
تمكن من مقاضاه رئيس سابق حيث اعتبر زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس شيوخ تشيكشمر ان
ترامب يخضع للقوانين نفسها التي يخضع لها
كل مواطن امريكي مشيرا الى انه سيتمكن من
الاستفاده من النظام القانوني لتقرير
مصيره وفقا للوقائع والقرن